Hello everybody, My name is Markiplier and welcome back to The Park.
Now we're going to be going on the Bumper cars,
And I wanted to say this game isn't quite what I thought it would be, I thought when it was-
Uhhg... When I first got here- Examine device?
Alright, I'll get back to that thought- woah.
-because apparently this is important.
[""No no no no no... Please no!"]
["Stop! Stop Doctor! Stop it please!"]
[in-game screaming]
W-well I can say for some sort of certainty that that was not normal.
That was one of those abnormal occurrences and also- what the hell was it?
Why was I being electro-zapped in a chair?
Okay, so, to finish my thought- I thought this game was gonna be more
"Open World Exploration"
And it /kinda/ is. Like I don't wanna knock it, it kinda is.
But also, I'm kinda on a path... Here.
I-I believe I can catch you, I just gotta find out how and why...
... And also where the hell I am.
So, like, what I mean by that is- of course you can go anywhere and I'm pretty sure there's a lot of hidden clues throughout the environment
-that tell the story in whatever way they can,
,but when I first heard about this game, I thought it was gonna be like a...
Y-You choose the way you go through it, and you choose the way you unravel the story.
And I'm not saying that's bad!
That's literally a thought that just popped into my head and it probably means absolutely dick-diddly
so ignore me! ...And why is that one on?
Markiplier: Callum!
["Callum, where are you?"]
Mmm.
How is it getting any power? There isn't exactly a grid up above there...
Because the way these things work is they get power by touching the
[loudly] electrified fence on the ceiling.
Oh good! Accident report!
Another one. Great. [sarcasm]
[pronounces name] FRANCIS... DEHFREEZNEH.
[reads report] "During the transport of bumper cars into the arena, one of the straps attaching the load to the trunk came untied causing a cascade of bumper cars onto Francis...
...who was standing, directing the driver."
"Francis was crushed by the weight of the car."
"Francis was killed!"
"Duuuuude... D-Dexter claims to have someone at the back of the load undoing the straps, no one else reported seeing anyone..."
"The sheriff requested that Dexter provide them his urine samples..."
"Double checking of the straps after transit should be mandatory and drug screenings for all drivers..."
"The local laborers are very superstitious and this hasn't helped"
so was it Chad?
Chad!
[crashing noises, suspenseful music]
Heeeeey! Wooaah! Heeeeeey!! Woooaaah!! [Markimoo lets out a very manly scream]
Oookaaay.
Very peculiar.
Huh.
Awfully, uh... suspicious and odd behavior.
["Callum! Where did you go?"]
Callum! This... car just came out of nowhere and tried to kill me! Come on!
Stop playing games with me...
I need you to be serious for one goddamn second!
Please!
["Callum?"]
["Caaallluuummm!"]
Markiplier: CaaaaaaaaaAAAALLUUUUM!
Callum?
[sound of baby crying]
Hmm... [sounds continue]
[more baby crying noises]
Mmmhmm.
[It's a matter of public record that I am a failure as a mother]
What?
[Once, when Callum was very small, I left him asleep in the car while I ran an errand. I don't even remember what it was.]
[When I came back, the Sheriff was standing next to the car, watching my boy through the window.]
[I didn't like what I saw in his eyes. Judgement.]
[He wrote me the ticket without saying a word, just the scratch-scratch of his pen on the notepad.]
[When he gave it to me, our eyes met.]
["I know what you're going through. My daughter, Helen, she... Just get some help"]
[Help was a bolt of lightning. Help was a thousand volts surging through my veins. Help is agony.]
["I'd rather die," I wanted to scream. "I'd rather you pulled your gun and shot me."]
[But instead my mouth said, "Yes, Sheriff."]
Oh, okay. I thought that was Chad over there.
It was just a poster of Chad.
Okay so that's very interesting. Why...... What is causing her so much stress in her life?
[reads from paper] "Continually delayed by the incompetence of the builders. The problem is that they're locals and they believe a lot of the rumors about what Old Man Henderson used to do here."
Markiplier: [loudly] What was it?!
And why call him Old Man Henderson?  That's such a nice name for someone who probably ate people.
[continues reading from paper] "They grew up on those tales. Every time a bolt comes loose or a wrench goes missing, those fools are crossing themselves against the black magic."
"Of course, that is why I chose this site over all of the other potential ones. Solomon Island is a nexus for dark energies... [unintelligibly mutters rest of sentence]"
Markiplier: Huuhhh???
Huh??
[reading from paper] "I called in a few favors back in Brooklyn and got someone at the local academy to see if they had any interesting books about local history."
"Turns out they do, and it turns out that Old Man Henderson had some pretty strong connections to the Brooklyn crowd."
"Perhaps something he wrote will help me find a piece of the plans that I'm missing."
Markiplier: Hang on! One second!
Huuuhhh??!
What the fuck are you talking about the 'Nexus for dark energy--'?
[loudly] It's a theme park!
What are you doing?!
Why??
[Scratch-scratch the nose]
Man, is that the guy at the entrance that we were talking to before?
["Mommy is coming, Callum."]
My God.
Oh, good! That baby's back!
I was wonderinin
I was won-der-ninin...
["Stay where you are!"]
Why is there a baby crying over there?
I'll be right with you baby, one second.
[So they are going to close the place down. Doesn't surprise me.]
Markimoo: You'd think that maybe it's already been closed???
Oh, back in 1980...
[reading from document] "After touring the park rides and viewing the startling number of incidents suffered here in the park,
"it is the inspectors opinion that Atlantic Island Park should be shut down until Nathaniel Winter complies with all safety regulations."
"While I understand that there is a sensitive political relationship between Mr. Winter and the Senator,"
"I nevertheless suggest that the political considerations be set aside in condemning Atlantic Island Park..."
(deep breath)
"The rides at first glance appear well constructed and maintained, but the sheer number of incidents at the park during the last few years and during construction..."
"...led me to believe that there is something wrong..."
"...at the base level of construction and we should close the park and fully investigate these flaws."
Mark: Like the Nexus for the 'dark energies'.
[reads from document] "To wit, here is a partial list of the fatalities in the park since opening only two years ago:
"Family of 3 killed..."
Markiplier: Eugh.
"Fourteen separate incidents of broken bones,"
"three suicides--"
Markimoo: aathluabd "Suicides."
[Continues reading document] "A child seriously injured from the-- on the escalator, over a dozen children reported missing in the House of Horrors..."
Ahh. You-- Hang on! Wait a minute.
Over a dozen. A dozen... m-missing... children...
...that have not been found yet?
[groan]
And just maaaaybe we'll close down this fuckin' place.
A Dozen... OVER a dozen. At least thirteen.
KIDS.
MISSING
Alright, and—
...one report of a drowning. But you know, whatever
C'est la vie
C'est la v-- ueugh
Can I decrease the speed ple—
No, not increase.
Slow it down!
I can't handle it.
[whispers] My stomach won't take it.
Decrease.
Decrease! ...Okay.
Can I get on it now?
Chad!
Gimme a biiggg hug.
Oh, boy. Here we go!
It's gonna go well.
I'll be sure to look out for any... Oh, hi!
What are you—
Hey—
Hang on a second.
Whatchu doing over there?
I saw that!
I saw that
Anyways, this time it's not gonna catch me off guard when a Giant Monstrosity™ leans in from the window...
Ah... This is nice.
This is the peaceful mountain air that I've always been hoping for.
Also...
...didn't they say we were outside of Brooklyn? Why are— why are there mountains?
Didn't they say that we were also on an island?
Why are there mountains? (Mark is confused)
["People come into your life for a reason." Dad used to say that before mom ran off. After that, he mostly just drank.]
Markiplier: What a wise man. (sarcasm intended)
[Things were different for Don and I.]
[When we met, I was sweeping the floor at Susie's Diner. He came in with some workers, but he didn't try to flirt or cop a feel like the others.]
[He just ordered a coffee and sat there, watching me.]
Markiplier: Creepy.
[When my shift was over, he offered to walk me home.]
[I don't know how to describe that walk. We talked and laughed and eventually, kissed.]
[It felt like love. It felt like a fairytale.]
[I can't tell you if Callum was made that night, or one of the ones that followed. But I think it has to be that night. That one perfect night.]
[Don and I moved in together but then, well... he died.]
[According to the supervisor, his safety harness failed when he was working on the top of the Ferris Wheel.]
[Don was there one moment,]
[and then gone.]
[Sometimes people leave your life for no reason.]
[I was three months pregnant with Callum. Fairytale fucking over.]
Markiplier: The ferris wheel that you're on right now. (LORAINNE)
And this is your... son's...favorite theme park. (IS FUCKING)
The one where his dad died. (TRIGGERED)
(WELL SHIT)
(Mark rubs his chin seductively)
I'm gonna hold my speculation until the Giant Monstrosity™ appears out from...
Hello!
Hi!
Alright, you're not the Giant Monstrosity™ but you look monstrous nonetheless.(SAVAGE)
I'm gonna increase the speed and then leave out, and hopefully this thing just tears itself to the ground.
'Cause I've got some questions....
I've got... Hoo, boy, I've got.. So. Many. Questions.
Because— Okay, first off, exactly what I said... about the story.
And second, "dark Nexus for magical energies"...
(FAKE ASS GRIN)
I—I dunno, I dun, I dun, I don't know!
I don't know.
Okay, so I'm just gonna leave this on.
...and hopefully it'll just break itself apart, because... it's probably what it deserves at this point.
Okay, goodbye! Goodbye abandoned ferris wheel!
["Where are you, Callum?"]
Markiplier: What was that sound?
Oh, there's still a baby over here.
Oh!
Oh, did it- Oh, it flung.
Oh, it flung one of the wheel cars.
["Mommy's coming, Callum!"]
Yeah.
Yup. Meanwhile I'm gonna reminisce about how shitty my life is.
Hello.
[noise]
Oh. Hi! Oh, okay. Goodbye!
Ookay.
(INTENSE TRIGGER)
Markiplier: Okay.
["This isn't a game, Callum!"]
Yeah, Callum! Come on. I'm starting to get angry.
["Don't do it, Mommy!"]
Markiplier: Don't do what?
["Come to mommy, Callum!"]
["Don't touch it!"]
Markiplier: Don't touch what?
["Callum!"]
["Mommy, he's watching you!"]
Markiplier: Who? Who's watching me? What am I not touching?
[A lot of people idolize their children. You hear them talking about their kids and just the say they talk... their fucking voices make me want to vomit.]
["My angel likes to read..." and "Little Johnny is so good on the piano..." Fuck those people.]
MARKIMOO
[You give up nine months of your life carrying them, you traumatize yourself giving birth to them and then you spend the rest of your life as their slave.]
[Wiping asses, mopping up piss, feeding them. Little life sucking monsters who take and take and take until...] (You alright there lady?)
[We all go insane. Any parent who pretends otherwise is just dishonest.]
[That's called choice-supportive bias.]
SHE'S FUCKIN GOIN AT IT!
[I am honest. Callum really grinds my gears. And he owes me everything. Everything.]
[It'd serve the little fuck right if I just abandoned him.]
Markiplier: O-kay.
["Callum, tell mommy where you are!"]
Markiplier: Okay, so-
["He's coming, Mommy!"]
Markiplier: W-Who is? Again, who?
There's some people and I noticed some dude at the ferris wheel, is that who you're talking about?
I've got a ride ticket 'cause-- I'm-I'm-I'm willing to bet that if I came here without this ride ticket it would've been like 'I can't get in without a ticket for some reason.'
But it's green now--
["I always wanted to ride this one, never got around to do it before."]
Ah, okay. It's-it's your kid's favourite--FAVOURITE--park, there's literally five rides at your kid's favourite park. You never got around to this one. You never got around to one of five.
N-Never? Alright, fine.
May- I could understand maybe the kid was too small to ride it, you know-- not tall enough, but
Suspending my disbelief a little bit
[quietly] Alright, let's get on.
That's not the point of this, though. That just irks me a little bit.
It's not the point of the story, though. Not the point of the story.
Oh, hi! Hello, sir! Okay, bye.
["What do you want?"]
["We need to talk about Callum."]
What the hell?
["What do you mean? What have you done to him?"]
["I? That's insulting. You and your boy are everything this place doesn't want - the antithesis of what we stand for."]
["Where is Callum?"]
["The poor child. He tried so hard to do what he was taught."]
Markiplier: [quietly] Oh, oh hi. ["He even left you a trail of breadcrumbs, but the park is just so hungry."]
Markiplier: Uh-huh.
["Tell me where my son is."]
["The witch has him now, has both of you. No happy ending here. I'm afraid."]
["Just...just leave me alone."]
["Fool. You always were."]
Markiplier:  I-I always were a fool?
Markiplier: Either I'm hallucinating or the dark energies are starting to get to me.
[mock-screams]
Oh, no.
Holy crap!
[uncertain] Okay. That's a little bizarre. That has to do with me being e-lec-tro-cu-ted?
I wanna get off the Mr. Bones Wild Ride. I didn't even read that [referring to sign], what the hell was that?
[crash] Woah-okay.
I can't read those words, they went by too quickly.
[crash] M: WeEeEeEeEe
Markiplier: Not safe, no joke!
"I can taste your dreams"? What the hell does that mean?
Wah, hey. Oh, God. Well, bye, Callum. [laughs]
Holy shit.
I have no idea. I have no- I have no idea.
[pause] I have no idea.
I have no idea what this game's message or main story is. And I'm not saying that's bad, I'm not saying it's bad. I'm just saying, like, from like what it has shown me, I have no idea.
[mutters] What the hell is happening here?
[reading off page on-screen] "It works! The calculations and adjustments worked. The transport and storage mechanisms seem to be flawless. What a wunderbar day!"
"If only these people knew what they were fueling."
"And so what if a few people leave the park at the end of the day feeling dour?"
"So what if the children are more scared than excited on the roller coaster?"
"This could be the doorway to immortality, and such doorways open only to those who have the will to find the key."
[pause] [loudly] WHAT THE FU-U-U-CK.
[calms down] -is going on.
'Nexus for dark energies'. Okay, anyway.
Markiplier: Sorry, just had to get that out of my system a little bit. Carrying on.
["I can help you, Callum."]
Markiplier: Callum. Where you at, Callum? I can help you, [dat eyebrow raise] apparently.
Man, so, okay. So if I was going to take a rational approach to this, lemme, let me just pause real quick-
-I get to take the flashlight and I get to go into the House of Horrors next-
So let me take a rational approach to this. 'Cause--I--let me suspend my disbelief for a second an-and get past the weird and try to tap into the actual story here, so-
Everybody, hold on. Everybody get out your notepads because this is gonna be complicated.
So, Old Man Henderson used to do sumping, something, on this land and it's a lot of land so whatever he did was apparently on a scale to such a large amount that it would have been hard to ignore by anyone- let alone the locals
if there’s something on the scales going on that scared, like, just the locals, you think it would’ve had a further reach than this- which seems like modern society.
-but again, push that aside for now. This other guy, Mr. Winter, came here knowing something about the thing that the Old Man Henderson was trying to do...
...with dark energies in this 'Nexus' and so his logical conclusion was to build a theme park. But, a-and that sounds weird but here's why-
in my understanding, it was to draw people in to do something similar to what Old Man Henderson was doing.
But instead of scaring the people, he wanted to absorb the joy that people were having at the theme park and kinda suck it out of them like, like a little filter for all their joy
they're having a good time but then it's getting sucked into the energy portal or some bullshit like that.
So, with all that being said, he's trying to use it to do something such as make himself immortal.
And, this main character is caught in the crossfire because she came to this park bringing her sadness
and she doesn't have happiness so what she adds to the park is actually negative emotions and negative energy so that's why she is not having a good time right now.
Markiplier: Okay.
["The witch awaits."]
Markiplier: 'The witch awaits'. I don't know what the hell that means.
That is my thought. Because, I try to rationalize these things and apparently the witch awaits and I know that
somehow because I talked to a guy who was sitting, spooning me from behind on the roller-coaster.
Markiplier: ...which was very nice admittedly.
[Callum has bruises on his arms, finger marks. Someone has been hurting him!]
[I've asked him, demanded really, to know where he got the marks.]
[But he doesn't want to answer me. Something has scared him into silence. He doesn't dare talk.]
[He's been changing too. Something sinister lurks in the darkness behind his eyes. I catch him staring at me at odd moments.]
[In the night he tosses and turns and cries out words I cannot understand.  When I try to soothe him, he snaps and tries to bite at my fingers.]
[I think he wants to talk to me. I think he wants to tell me.]
[But they are watching him, every minute of the day. They are whispering to him in his sleep, changing him.
[They are taking my baby away from me!]
[I can save him. There will be pain.]
But I love him and in the end he will understand why]
Okay, so... that kinda confirms what I was talking about.
He came to this park and apparently he got possessed by something?
I'm not sure if that's the right word for it in this universe
but, that's my thoughts. So, either this is a distorted version of reality and she's having a rough time, or this is actually...
literally right here. No wait, it's the...
It's either distorted version of reality or this is l- all in her mind and I'm leaning towards the latter on that one.
I don't think that this could be, in any way, actually real.
[crash]
...Okay. (mumbles)
[reading screen]
Oh wouldn't you know!
Mark: Was it an eyeball?
[reading screen]
Mark: So what does that bring the grand total up to?
Over a dozen plus one now?
How many kids? I guess this isn't exactly a missing kid, this is just... dead.
Fu—
[THIS ISN'T A GAME CALLUM!]
Mark: I heard that!
I ain't gonna take you! What are you talking about?
[noise] What the fuck was that?
A-ohhh. Blood. Hey. Oh, blood. Oh, trail of blood.
Mark: I should follow!
[Mark making annoyed noises]...maybe if you stopped bitching and did your work—
And by work, I mean push the witch into the oven and I guess that was the whole reason-
[spots blood]
Wooh. [pause]
Hey, stop stip-stepping.
[ominous noise/tense music]
Mark: Hmm, okay.
That's weird.
Is he dead?
He's not actually dead, is he?
[distant noises of infrastructure]
Oh, okay.
Alright then-
Hello, did you do this?
Did you do it? [silence]
Okay, fine.
Maybe I should-
Hey, hi, hi Chad!
Oh, really? Oh, okay.
I-I knew something was up when I couldn't back up.
But, uh-
Good thing that was totally not a threat to me in any way.
He almost had me there.
Alright, /Chad/.
You wanna play, Chad?
Huh, Chad?
Is that you stip-stepping, Chad?
[quietly] Huh?
[quietly] Hello.
Okay.
'Take pills'? W-hmm-I- [more unintellible muttering]
[unintelligible Mark noises] I dunno about—I don't—
Strange bottle of pills, hmm.
First thing, take it? Hmm, I don't know. Okay, fine.
Markiplier: T-t-these are mine.
They're mine now.
They're mine.
Just as tasty as I remember.
Oh, oh, boy.
[repeatedly says 'oh, boy']
Does that say [stumbles over words]
"Destroy reality."
[reading graffiti]
[unintelligible] I took some strange pills, Callum.
Oh boy.
Where the heck am I now...
"Don't believe anything they tell you." Yeah, I wasn't about to start.
Hello?
Who is that- What is that?
[distorted amusement park music]
[slowly] I'm sorry.
Oh boy.
Oh, where did I just come from?
Ooh, nicely did.
Nicely did!
I like that.
[distorted voice] "Don't leave me here Callum"
Callum!
Dang it, Callum.
Bam!
Oh those worked.
Ookay.
[weird laughing of sorts]
Callum: Don't touch me!
I—...O-okay.
Hello!
[reading screen, getting increasingly confused]
[still reading, but more maniacally. also with more voice-cracking]
[maximum passion is being reached. he's really feeling the reading]
[Overloading the passion, ears begin to bleed around the world]
Oh you're wel- yes thank you- thank you for the applause. I know, that was definitely worth reading right then and there.
I'm assuming that was supposed to be gibberish for a reason.
Callum!
Callum?
'Pic-pickled Pickled Punks' Okay.
Ughh.
Pickled babies ugh.
Callum: Mommy I'm scared!
Okay. Me too.
I'm also trippin BALLS.
Okie-dokie then.
[laboured breathing]
Oh oh, that's not good.
That's not good at all!
Ugh.
[tense music builds up]
Okay time for a nap.
Well!
Okay.
Why did I need to take those pills?
I didn- I didn't actually see myself taking them so, I'm assuming just picking them up made things go wrong.
So that- that was actually all in her mind.
So that was an example of what that was and I wanna see what's going on here.
What the hell was all that?
Was there really nothing else to that?
Was there really nothing else to this dead body over here?
That's still over there for some reason?
We're not all worried about that?
[breathing in]
Alright, off we go then! Why not?
No kidding!
Okay. Your narration took a sinister turn as well. Not a hundred percent sure... why?
Callum: Follow the breadcrumbs
[mocking] Follow the breadcrumbs. What breadcrumbs? There ain't no breadcrumbs, but I'm gonna be going in there in the next episode.
This is WILD. This is a wild ride.
I-I I also want to reiterate. I am NOT bashing this game in any way just because I criticize some of the finer points in the story.
I'm having a wonderful time. I'm having a fantastic time trying to discern the MiNd BoGgLinG 0-o insanity that is being put in front of me.
And it is really cool, but I just wanted to point that out so people don't think that I'm being mean to this game.
I'm b-being playfully bantery to this game, but not mean. No meanness intended, this is actually pretty cool.
So, Thank you everybody so much for watching! I'll get to the next part very soon~
And as always, I will see you in the next video.  Buh-bye!